a gym that specializes in weight loss
offers its members an optional dietary
program for an extra fee
to study the effectiveness of the
dietary program a manager at the gym
takes a random sample of 50 members who
participate in the dietary program and
50 members who don't
the manager finds that those who
participated in the dietary program on
average lost significantly more weight
than those who didn't participate in the
program in the past three months
the manager concludes that the dietary
program caused the increased weight loss
for the gyms members during that time
period
so pause this video and see and think
about whether you think the manager is
making a valid conclusion based on this
study
all right so let's first just make sure
we understand what the manager is
concluding the manager is saying that
there's a causal relationship between
the dietary program that being on the
dietary program causes increased
weight
weight loss
and they would be able to make this
conclusion if it's a well-designed
experimental study
and you might say well what does an
experimental study look like well in an
experimental study you have a control
group that wouldn't have the dietary
program and then you would have a
treatment or experimental group that
does have the dietary program and then
you would see hey if these folks are
actually seeing more weight loss and if
it's statistically significant then
maybe you can conclude the causal
relationship that the dietary program is
causing the weight loss and this kind of
looks like that
until you think about how folks were
assigned to either of these groups
it would be a well-designed experimental
study if you took
random samples from the broader
population so you took a random sample
so that's a random sample from the
broader population and then
from this group you randomly assign
folks to either of the control or the
treatment so you're randomly assigning
and then the people who happened to be
in the treatment group not the people
who chose to be in it well those people
you'd say you need to be on this diet
and you make sure that they are on that
diet and then if you see a statistically
significant increased weight loss then
you might be able to make this
conclusion
but that's not what happened over here
in this
situation
in this situation we didn't randomly
select from the broader population and
then randomly assign folks to these
groups
what happened is
people self-selected into either being
in the dietary program or not being in
the dietary program i'll say not the
dietary program
and then what they did is is that they
randomly sampled from the dietary
program to put them in i guess you could
say the the treatment group and then
they randomly sampled from this control
group and so in this situation you have
a significant confounding variable
people essentially self-selected
themselves into the dietary program
group and that you could view as a
confounding variable and so it doesn't
allow you to make this causal connection
because people who selected themselves
into the dietary program maybe they're
more motivated to lose weight maybe they
could afford the money and that wealth
association is associated with being
able to eat better and maybe being able
to lose more weight now a conclusion
that the manager might be able to make
based on this study is that there is an
association between participating in the
dietary program and weight loss but once
again you can't establish the causality